[Music]
aloha dc fandom i apologize for the
four-year wait oh my gosh we've been
here since
2017. but i'm very proud of the sequel
because it's tackling a lot of issues
environmentally stakes are higher and
i'm just excited because i had a big
part in my boy james you know
check it out i'm excited for you to see
it the tides are changing it's important
the tabs are changing
like the comic book the world of aquaman
is so big
and so rich it's epic it's huge it's
colorful
the world is at stake i'm super excited
to be back making the sequel
i have so much invested into it i love
this character i love what it represents
there's nothing that i've ever been a
part of that's like this people are
going to be in for a treat when aquaman
2 comes out they're going to get a movie
that's more mature
but yet still retain it's fun
to give the audience something different
something new that they haven't seen
before the success of that movie as the
biggest dc movie of all time shows what
james wan wanted his team were able to
do and in this second film we have
turned the dials up to 11. it has the
action the fun the heart
action
two superheroes and super villains have
entertained generations of fans across
the globe okay you got it we put that in
the movie
to play around with this cast again it's
quite a trip we're having a blast this
movie's a lot of fun
i think fans are going to be very happy
i think james is really excited to go
all out
this is an exciting thing we better get
to a little bit of action
it's gonna be a fun adventure like it
was the first time
just better
we see that black panther is still
seeking his vengeance to try and kill
aquaman
that's gonna be something that's
exciting for the audience something for
them to be swept up into the world of
aquaman again
about uh kicks my ass
it's a globetrotting story
we visit so many different worlds this
movie isn't afraid to embrace its
fantasy and go on this magical journey i
think it's going to be really awesome
[Music]
you